hello everyone how are you
super excited about this we're going to
jump right in uh what we are going to do
is i'm going to give a overview of the
current state of the uh economic
situation in the united states and the
way i'm going to do that is i'm going to
start first
looking backwards i'm going to go ahead
and say to myself all right well what
happened going all the way back to
the beginning of
2020 and then we'll work our way all the
way through to the point in time now i
think that should help people understand
not only one where we've been but also
where uh where we're going uh from here
as well and so if you start out and
look going into uh 2020 uh the economy
actually was pretty strong uh the
economy had uh a bunch of things going
for it so we had a very low um
unemployment rate about 3.5 percent it
was at a historic low
and inflation was under control
everything looked pretty good uh there
was some warning signs in 2019 there was
things like inverted yield curves there
was some high degree of ceos leaving
their jobs uh but those were all things
that um made you pay attention but
didn't necessarily signal that there was
uh something bad on uh on the horizon um
and so once we got into 2020 obviously i
don't think very many people saw or if
nobody saw a global pandemic
that was going to hit and so
uh when you think about this
pandemic
it was very unique in that it forced
governments
to order everyone to sit at home now you
can debate the merits of whether they
should have done that they shouldn't
have done that was it effective was it
not but that is what happened um and so
when you look at
that march 2020 uh time frame
governments all around the world went
and forced everyone to sit at home well
if you force people to sit at home what
occurs is that you essentially slow the
velocity of money and so people can't
come into your store
or your store shut down then obviously
the economic output of that economy is
going to drastically drop uh and so the
second that those governments ordered
people to sit at home the second that
velocity of money started to slow of
course every single investor in the
market says well i don't know what's
going to happen there's uncertainty
there's fear there's chaos and so what
am i going to do i'm going to hold on to
my assets
on top of holding on to my assets i also
am going to turn around uh and try to
raise dollars and so what people
basically did is they looked at their
portfolio and they said anything with a
liquid market whether it's stocks
whether it was bonds currencies
commodities crypto anything that had a
liquid market sell it i want dollars in
time of uncertainty i want dollars and
so what we saw in that moment
was that there was a liquidity crisis
everyone wanted dollars in march of 2020
and so naturally what you got was a
strengthening dollar as more people
wanted the dollar and you had asset
prices all selling off because people
were literally dumping assets to get
those dollars and so when that occurs uh
all correlations of assets goes towards
one so you can have all of the
non-correlated assets in the world but
during a liquidity crisis all asset
correlations go towards one that's what
we saw happen uh in march of 2020. now
there's two schools of thought when that
occurred is that the federal reserve
central bank of the united states they
could have sat there and said hey let's
let the free market go ahead and handle
this uh we see that there are asset
prices falling uh gold went down about
15 stocks were down about 25
uh bitcoin was down 50 percent in a
single day uh or we can step in we can
intervene and so as we know the federal
reserve decided they were going to step
in they were going to intervene and when
they decided to intervene in that
situation
they have basically two tools
at their disposal every central bank
regardless of the financial situation
they can either manipulate interest
rates up or down the cost of capital
make it more expensive or cheaper
and they can conduct uh quantitative
easing they can basically
create money and put it into the
financial system uh and so they chose uh
to do both um and it was the federal
reserve and the central bank but it was
also uh fiscal policy as well and so if
you kind of think of the totality of
what occurred is that we got two
emergency interest rate cuts down to a
zero percent interest rate environment
uh that made the cost of capital uh
basically you know as cheap as it's been
in a very long time uh there's a
negative rate in other parts of the
world uh and then we created trillions
of dollars and we stuffed it into every
exotic corner of the financial system
and so when you look at that you
basically say to yourself why are they
doing that why did they do that in 2020
and the reason why they did this is
because they were trying to stimulate
the economy that's why it's called
monetary stimulus you're trying to
stimulate the economy and so naturally
you drive the cost of capital down to
zero meaning that you're trying to
incentivize people to borrow money and
then go spend it in the economy and then
you also give money all across the
entire uh financial system and so what
you do is you stuff it in every corner
you possibly can and so naturally when
they were doing this there was a small
group of folks uh usually the bitcoin uh
community uh who said wait a minute
you're not gonna be able to do this
without massive massive repercussions
but the thought process was uh among the
central bankers and also politicians
that we don't get paid for solving
long-term problems we get paid for
addressing short-term problems and so
what they basically did was they made a
trade-off they said we are going to
optimize to mitigate short-term pain
and no matter what happens over the long
term we'll deal with that later and so
what we ended up seeing was exactly that
they went ahead and they mitigated that
short-term pain
uh through the monetary stimulus and
physical stimulus
and they said whatever happens in the
future we'll deal with it later and
naturally if you go ahead and you
incentivize people to borrow money they
borrow money and they borrow a lot of
money and if it's at zero percent
interest rate they borrow as much money
as they possibly can
and then if you go ahead and you
actually hand out money either through
asset purchases stuffing it into the
financial system or you say we're
literally going to send checks directly
to people sitting at home naturally
what's going to happen is that you're
going to stimulate the economy that's
exactly what happened is all those asset
prices that sold off again gold down 15
stocks down 25 bitcoin down 50 they
exploded upwards and from pretty much
april may of 2020 all the way through
the end of 2021 what we got was a
historic asset stimulus a asset
appreciation and so what you end up
seeing is last year in 2021 the stock
market was up 30 percent
real estate prices in america for homes
was up about 20
bitcoin was up 65
these are all massive numbers all lots
and lots of appreciation and the reason
is because the market was being
manipulated they basically were pumping
air into a balloon and as they were
pumping that air into the balloon the
balloon got bigger and bigger and bigger
and bigger and so asset prices continued
to rise now as that occurred naturally
if asset prices are going up so does the
price of consumer goods and this is
something that gets lost in the
conversation a lot but if you think of
assets assets are financial assets
things that you can purchase
from an investment standpoint their
stocks their sponsors currencies
commodities uh real estate crypto etc
but
if you are going to increase the
price of these assets you simultaneously
also increase the price of other things
you can buy and so the other bucket is
basically consumer goods and so this is
everything from gasoline to food uh to
cars etc and so even though food or
gasoline aren't thought of as an
investment to the average american
family they're still assets and so
naturally as you got the market
manipulated what you saw was that there
was a massive increase in investment
asset prices and a massive increase in
consumer goods and so that's where the
inflation comes from is that you got
this inflation number that started to
creep up and going into the end of 2020
the inflation was still pretty much
under control at the start of 2021
inflation was still you know kind of two
three percent uh and we didn't get a
five percent inflation number five
percent year-over-year growth until
about june of 2021 the summer time of
2021 and we pretty much haven't gone
under we haven't gone under five percent
since then we have stayed at over five
percent inflation in the united states
which is more than two and a half times
uh the federal uh reserves intra uh
inflation target for now going on one
full year for a year we have been at
over five percent inflation right now we
set it over eight percent inflation and
that is based on a cpi metric the
consumer price index which is absolutely
incorrect it's a manipulated number so
even if we give them credit and say that
the number's right it's still showing
over eight percent showing over five
percent for 12 months
but
that number is definitely incorrect and
i'll give you a couple of examples for
example if you look at something like
shelter shelter still shows anywhere
between two to five percent
year-over-year increase over the last 12
months that's the numbers they've been
telling us but real estate prices are up
20 percent in rent national averages of
about 20 as well across the country so
to buy a home and live in it is up 20
percent or to rent is up 20 percent how
is shelter up only 2 to 5
well you then can go and take a look at
how do they calculate that number and
when you think about this what i'm about
to tell you is absolutely insane they
literally call
people on the phone and they say hey
what's your rent how much were you
paying last year how much are you paying
now and the way that they determine that
is i think it's the 1980 census data
they identified about 60 000 locations
in that from that census data and they
call a certain number of them every
single month now the reason why that's
interesting is because
ultimately that is not a very good uh
kind of uh holistic view of rent as an
example in the united states if you go
and look at something like apartment.com
if you go and look at something like
zillow they have
millions of data points in real time on
their websites and they show anything
between seven eight percent uh rental
increases or real estate increases all
the way up to as high as 15 percent and
so if the official cpi number is showing
two to five percent but some of these
websites are telling us seven to fifteen
percent you can then infer that it's
much more likely that the private
companies who have access to more data
and in real time holistically across the
country their data is more accurate and
therefore they're closer to reality than
the official numbers and so my
estimation is that inflation has reached
double digit percentage at this point
low double digit percentage and that's
why you're seeing so much pain over the
last two years for the bottom 45 percent
of americans remember the bottom 45
percent of americans have no investable
assets so one of the key understandings
around inflation is that as inflation
occurs it inflates the price of
investments and it inflates the price of
consumer goods now if you're a wealthy
person you have a lot of investments the
percentage of your net worth that is
spent on a month-to-month basis
on consumer goods is low you don't worry
about the pain from the inflation on the
consumer goods because you're making so
much money in your portfolio and if you
are in the bottom 45 percent of
americans you have the exact opposite
problem you have no investments and 100
of the money you spend is on consumer
goods so when those prices go up you end
up being hurt and so naturally what
occurs is that rich people love
inflation they get rich look at how much
money was made from march of 2020 until
the end of 2021. the people who don't
like inflation are the people who have
no investment so investors win in high
inflation environments and consumers
lose in high inflation environments and
so when you think about that i always
like to joke and say that inflation
would end tomorrow if rich people
weren't making money now how do you end
inflation that's exactly what the
federal reserve has been trying to
figure out they thought that inflation
was transitory they continued to talk
about inflation is transitory inflation
is transitory obviously it turned out
not to be transitory uh and now it is
persistent they've given up on using
that nomenclature they now admit that
they were wrong they didn't foresee the
problem etc and so the question becomes
how can they solve the inflation problem
well the only way that they really can
do it again go back to the tools that
they have or they can either one
manipulate interest rates or two asset
purchases quantitative easing or
quantitative tightening and so exactly
those two tools are now being used in
november they started to quote talk
tough they started to say hey inflation
is kind of out of hand we're going to
have to address this it's not
necessarily transitory we're going to
have to do something here and so at
first they just started to talk talk
they try to give people a warning say
hey we're going to have to address this
we're going to have to address this
what they have done since then is they
have started to increase interest rates
meaning they are making capital more
expensive in the market and also at the
same time they are now not making asset
purchases they actually are conducting
quantitative tightening they are trying
to shrink the federal reserve's balance
sheet if you go back to 2008 2009 the
federal reserve's balance sheet at that
time was about 900 billion dollars today
9 trillion so a 10x since the global
financial crisis so they are going to
try to conduct quantitative tightening
and drastically increase interest rates
all while having over eight percent
inflation we've never seen them really
try to do this before especially in our
lifetime and so when you start to think
about this why are asset prices going
down well if they are conducting
quantitative easing meaning that they
are actually making loose monetary
policy they're making cheap capital
available and they're stuffing liquidity
into the market asset prices go up well
if all of a sudden they do the opposite
quantitative tightening they make
capital expensive by increasing interest
rates and they are selling or
contracting the assets on their balance
sheet then you obviously are going to
get an inverse reaction so asset prices
come down a lot of people will talk
about this as they basically are putting
that air in the balloon now they're
letting the air out of the balloon so
you get this kind of contraction of the
uh of the asset prices and that's what
we've watched happen pretty much since
november of last year is stocks
commodities bonds real estate crypto all
of it's going down and it's going down
specifically because the fed is the
single most important player in the
market and when they say it's going to
be good times we're going to have a
loose monetary policy asset prices
explode when they say hey we're in
control we're going to conduct
quantitative tightening asset prices go
down so literally the federal reserve is
creating this situation the reason why
they are willing to create this
situation is because they are trying to
get inflation under control now one of
the issues that they have to deal with
which makes this even more complex is
not only is inflation still above eight
percent but in q1 they were expecting an
annualized economic growth number of gdp
in the united states to be plus over one
percent plus one percent so on a take q1
growth annualize it it'd be over one
percent instead what they got was a
negative 1.4
number meaning that the
u.s economy in q1 contracted on an
annualized rate at negative 1.4
so if you have high inflation you have a
contracting economy you have increasing
interest rates you have quantitative
tightening and you have falling asset
prices this is not good this is not a
good situation and so naturally an
economy
of the size of the united states or any
economy around the world it's hard it's
very difficult to understand how your
actions as a central bank are going to
impact all of the nuances now it's not
hard to understand hey if we create
trillions of dollars and stuff it into
the economy and we drop interest rates
to zero we may create consumer price
uh inflation
because you're also trying to pump asset
prices higher which is exactly what they
did and there was scandals at the
federal reserve where federal reserve
presidents were literally day trading
the exact assets that the federal
reserve was buying they were in the
market trading their personal accounts
at the same time
but when you think about this now the
federal reserve is faced with the
following situation
we have committed to raise interest
rates we've done two interest rate uh
increases so far
and we have committed and are now
conducting quantitative tightening we
are contracting our balance sheet as we
are doing that asset prices are falling
as asset prices are falling we also in
q1 saw a contraction in the u.s economy
if they continue through the end of this
year the market at one point was pricing
in 10 interest rate rises and an
interest rate of 300 basis points a 3
interest rate by the end of the year if
they were to continue to do that the
federal reserve will push us into a
absolute
very dangerous recession they will force
us into a recession and they may be
successful in getting inflation to come
down but they would push us into a new
fight into a recession and so naturally
what ends up occurring is that people
talk about this idea of a soft landing
how does the federal reserve guide the
u.s economy to a soft landing that would
be inflation coming down
no recession
and
they would end up being able to
stabilize asset prices so even though
the asset prices had come down they
would find some equilibrium or market
bottom and they then would go sideways
now the problem with that is that would
require some minute control over the
economy that's not how the economy works
if you look at a data point that they
always talk about they talk about 3.5
3.6 unemployment right now which is
again very close to that historic low
that we were in february of 2020 right
before the pandemic but the only problem
is now as they are raising interest
rates as they're conducting quantitative
tightening as the economy is contracting
and asset prices are falling you can see
all these companies now starting to
announce hiring freezes they're
announcing layoffs we've seen in the
crypto um uh ecosystem coinbase gemini
etc many companies hiring freezes or
they're actually laying off 10 to 25 of
their staff
and so naturally what my expectation
here would be is that you're gonna see
that unemployment numbers start to tick
up because
they're causing a recessionary like
event whether we actually get to a
recession or not it remains to be seen
but they are pushing us in that way and
if they are successful in convincing the
market that they are going to continue
to raise interest rates and conduct
quantitative tightening people are going
to stop trying to grow their businesses
they are going to say i need to just
weather the storm i need to shore up my
balance sheet have a strong balance
sheet and i need to make sure i get to
the other side of this that's exactly
what we're seeing people do hiring
freezes and also layoffs and so
naturally what we should see here is we
should continue to see them try to raise
interest rates i do not believe they'll
get to 10 interest rate raises i do not
believe they'll get to the 300 basis
points interest rate my base case is
that at some point they are going to
pause interest rate increases before the
end of the year and i think that there
is a higher chance than most people are
assigning that they will actually do an
interest rate cut before the end of the
year now why do i think that well some
of it is because the economy is
contracting some of that is because we
already see layoffs starting to occur
and it's likely that that's going to
accelerate over the next two to six
weeks but also don't forget we are in a
midterm election
and in november the worst thing that you
can do
yes you could go into an election with
high inflation but the worst thing would
be to go into the uh election in a
recession
and so naturally what are we watching
play out here we are watching the soft
landing if you're just looking at
economics that's
already incredibly difficult some would
argue impossible
but if you have the midterm election
also coming up as you saw last week joe
biden calling in jerome powell and
saying hey i need you to come to the
principal's office i need you to come
explain to me what's going on here we're
going into a midterm election i need you
to figure out how the hell to get down
inflation get down gas prices i need you
to get down
all these problems now not only are we
also headed towards uh the midterm
elections but remember the pandemic
caused all sorts of supply chain issues
as well so if you lock down
all these people in their homes we saw
ships off the coast of america we saw
all sorts of supply chain disruptions in
china and other places where we had
outsourced our manufacturing the us
realized that they had been exposed they
had basically chased all this efficiency
around the world low cost high
efficiency
and what they've given up was resiliency
most manufacturing is not done in the
united states and so as we figured that
out we realized we were dependent on
these other countries and there's a
chain reaction if they shut down their
country then it takes longer for these
goods to get to us and so you had
monetary policy fiscal policy economic
environment and then supply chain issues
all contributing to higher and higher
inflation
now those supply chain issues in many
cases have not been resolved the
monetary policy situation is not acting
fast enough to necessarily get inflation
back to the two percent uh federal
reserve uh inflation target
and then add in a third variable which
is the russia ukraine conflict why well
the russian ukraine region happens to be
one of the largest exporters of oil and
natural gas and it also happens to be
one of the largest wheat producers and
it also happens to be one of the largest
producers of fertilizer so of all of a
sudden there's a shock to the fertilizer
ecosystem and supply chain that means
that more and more people will not be
able to use that fertilizer to then have
global food production come in at the
same level that you would have expected
in past years if all of a sudden wheat
ends up being disrupted then that ends
up having a huge impact on global food
as well then you look at oil and natural
gas we've seen all sorts of sanctions
and issues one of the complaints though
that i think people around the world
have is countries in europe specifically
like germany and others they over the
last few years have bought into the esg
narrative which basically is a school of
thought that says hey we should do quote
unquote right by the environment which
sounds amazing and we should give up our
own energy independence
think about that they gave up energy
independence to pursue a feel-good story
now they are dependent because they
don't have their own independence they
are dependent on countries like russia
for oil and natural gas and so naturally
they are forced to buy oil and natural
gas from russia which also because of
the supply chain because of conflicts
because of monetary policy has
drastically increased in price and so
what you get is a complete mess that's
what we're watching right now the global
economy is a complete mess we get
monetary policy that created high
inflation fiscal policy that created
high inflation we then got asset prices
that exploded upwards as asset prices
went up there was tons of easy money to
be made as tons of easy money was made
then we got people who became
undisciplined investors they started
yoloing into all sorts of assets across
uh the economy as all of that occurred
we then got a federal reserve and now a
chain reaction of other central banks
saying wait a second we have to get this
under control we're acting too late we
have high inflation we need to address
it let's start to raise interest rates
let's conduct quantitative tightening we
then have high inflation we have
quantitative tightening we've been
contracting us economy we have supply
chain disruptions with the russian
ukraine conflict and on top of all that
we have no known understanding of what
is happening in the future and so going
into a midterm election this is an
absolute nightmare if you look at gas
prices in their correlation to the
president or to politicians it is
spilling a complete wipeout of the
democratic party in the midterm election
because gasoline
the national average is now
4.50 people in california are paying as
much as eight dollars for a gallon of
gasoline this is insane
and so naturally if you start to look
and you say to yourself okay
well let's look at stocks
value stocks that have cash flow and
their earnings are uh providing value
that there's uh equity value assigned to
those earnings today
they're gonna do okay and that's where
you saw berkshire hathaway hit an
all-time high except those value stocks
uh or kind of non-growth stocks will
continue to perform uh decently well all
growth all tech stocks etc they're down
significantly in some cases they're down
30 40 50 some as much as 80 or 90
percent and so those are heavily
correlated risk on assets when there's
loose monetary policy so those have come
down if you then look at things like uh
real estate again real estate prices are
a function of supply and demand and
demand is heavily influenced by the
interest rate interest rates are going
up there's less demand if there's less
demand then that means that over time
you should see prices come down on real
estate if you look at something like
bitcoin and cryptocurrencies what's
unique there is going into 2020 bitcoin
specifically was held by retail
investors there was very few
institutions that were uh actually going
ahead and
participating if you there's no public
companies holding it that were
non-crypto companies uh there was very
few wall street institutions etc but
going into
august september of 2020 we saw two
specific developments one was michael
saylor and microstrategy they started to
buy bitcoin and talk about it publicly
that led to square and tesla also buying
bitcoin and putting it on their public
balance sheets we also saw paul tudor
jones and eventually stanley
druckenmiller and many others start
talking about using bitcoin as an
inflation hedge that they're going to
put in their portfolio and so what that
did is that basically removed the career
risk for people on wall street to go
ahead and start to allocate
their funds to bitcoin and now there's
two things that occurred with bitcoin's
price bitcoin was trading between eight
thousand and ten thousand dollars at the
time is that we saw a ton of people who
previously weren't holding it start the
buyers the price should go up uh as that
occurs but also at the same time there
was a highly illiquid market one of the
reasons is because there was a bunch of
people on wall street that started
trying to arb the gbtc premium they
would go in the private market they
would give uh grayscale money they would
then
because there's no redemption
functionality that bitcoin would just
sit inside of gbtc
and so what occurred between november of
uh 2020 and march of 2021 is bitcoin
went from about 10 000 up to 64 000
600 plus increase in the price of
bitcoin
mostly driven because new players came
in the market
and the players who had already been
around they weren't willing to sell
their bitcoin and so when you have high
illiquidity in the market and new buyers
show up they say i'll buy your bitcoin
for 10k everyone says i'm not selling it
to you i'll buy it for 11k
nobody sells it 15k nobody sells 20k
nobody wants to sell 25 30 35 50.
dollars then people start selling it to
them and so you got this kind of
equilibrium in price
now one of the questions i always get is
hey i thought bitcoin was non-correlated
asset well bitcoin is a non-correlated
asset over a long period of time and so
naturally what you get is in march of
2020 bitcoin is highly correlated
there's liquidity crisis all asset
prices are correlated during a liquidity
crisis they trend towards one right now
what's occurred is because so many of
those wall street investors and those
kind of sophisticated institutional
investors started to buy bitcoin bitcoin
is the riskiest thing in their portfolio
so when they go risk off they sell their
tech stocks they sell their growth
stocks they sell bitcoin etc and they
got a lot of money and so what we've
seen since november is that the
institutions the whales they've been
selling a lot of their bitcoin and we've
seen continued increasing in the dollar
cost averaging of the plugs the retail
investors in bitcoin we just crossed
over 10 million wallet uh bitcoin
addresses with at least i think it's
0.01 bitcoin uh in their wallet and
those are just people who have a couple
hundred dollars worth of bitcoin we
continue to hit all-time high after
all-time high after all-time high there
and so naturally what has occurred is
that we've gotten a flush out of a lot
of the institution most of the
institutions that we're gonna sell
they've sold that's where you see
bitcoin uh really kind of going sideways
now and trading between 25 35 000 price
point which sounds super volatile but in
bitcoin terms uh isn't nearly as
volatile as let's say if that was in the
stock market or somewhere else
and so this idea of non-correlation over
a long period of time bitcoin is a
non-correlated asset but in times where
correlations of assets goes towards one
liquidity crisis or in a quantitative
tightening environment you get very high
correlation that's where you see
bitcoin's correlation to nasdaq as an
example hitting an all-time high uh is
because they're being treated the exact
same from institution and professional
investors now the other question i get a
lot around bitcoin specifically is i
thought bitcoin is supposed to be an
inflation hedge inflation's at eight
percent what the hell one of the things
you have to understand is that
inflation hedges go up in value before
the inflation shows up
think about it if i think inflation is
coming like paul tudor jones thought
inflation was coming sitting there in q3
of 2020 i don't wait for the inflation
to show up before i move my money i move
my money in anticipation of the
inflation and so what we saw was before
we ever got a five percent inflation
reading bitcoin went from ten thousand
to sixty four thousand dollars that was
people moving their money to be prepared
and positioned in a high inflation
environment and so naturally now that we
have high inflation guess what those
people did really well even though
bitcoin's prices come down is now around
30 000
that's still a 300 percent increase from
where it was in q3 of 2020. and if you
go all the way back to before the
pandemic and you look at asset prices or
asset classes and their performance
bitcoin has outperformed stocks it's
outperformed bonds outperformed
commodities it's outperformed real
estate it's outperformed currencies etc
bitcoin has been the best place to go
over the last two years now that doesn't
mean that this is going to be the best
place over the next two years it doesn't
mean uh that this is financial advice
and you should go out and buy bitcoin it
just simply says looking back over the
last two years if you had to go back to
february of 2020 and do it all over
again you would have put your money in
bitcoin over stocks bonds currencies uh
commodities real estate etc and so
bitcoin was the best inflation hedge
asset it also serves as a non-correlated
asset over a long period of time and so
naturally what we end up seeing here is
people are very miseducated when it
comes to these nuances of the financial
system and so what we see at the bottoms
of markets all the time is people start
yelling about things going to zero
things are over it's all over it's all
over it's all over uh and i think that
uh there is um a understanding that fear
drives these markets we can look at the
fear and greed index as one example it's
at like 10 to 15.
super super fearful everyone's fearful
all over the entire market uh but i
think that this is uh a time where you
have to step back for a second and say
okay
if i am going to look at allocating
assets
what do i think is going to be around
five or ten years from now if you are
actually a long-term investor
what is the most uh kind of attractive
thing from here now i personally is me
speaking so not financial advice this is
my view is that bitcoin at 30 000. where
it was back in january of 2021 18 months
ago
and
it has higher uh hash rate it has higher
uh um active wallets it has uh uh
all-time high number of people dollar
cost averaging with bitcoin addresses on
chain etc all those metrics are up
lightning network all of it's up
but i get the same price
pretty attractive some may argue that
that would be a value investors analysis
of an asset like bitcoin now the big
problem that people are going to have to
face here is are we going to actually go
into a recession how bad will it be and
how long will it last if we get there i
don't know i don't know if we're going
to actually go into a recession odds are
we will see more economic contraction
this year but let's see what the q2 uh
gdp number ends up being what i do think
is that the federal reserve is committed
in the short term to continue to raise
interest rates and also uh quantitative
tightening i do not think that we get to
the end of the year and they still are
aggressively pursuing both of those
strategies i could be wrong but we'll
see
and i think that there is an outsized
chance uh that they end up actually
trying to stimulate the economy before
the end of the year with either kind of
a half-hearted interest rate cut uh or
some sort of stopping of the
quantitative tightening so that they can
go ahead and tell people hey it's gonna
be okay asset prices stop falling
mid-term elections let's keep going so
what can you do ends up being the next
question and i think the biggest thing
that people need to understand is
there's not a lot you can do you got to
focus on what you can control you can't
control monetary policy no matter how
much you tweet how much you complain how
much you write articles how much you
talk to your friend your barber the taxi
driver your wife your husband your
neighbor
you can't control monetary policy you
also can't control fiscal policy you
also can't control the stock market what
you can control though is you can
control the strength of your balance
sheet so if you've got a business you
got to make sure that you strengthen
that balance sheet as fast as possible
go raise equity get a revenue in get
capital on your balance sheet so you can
ensure that you're going to be here two
years from now if you don't survive you
can't thrive later you got to survive
the bad times so you can thrive in the
good times now the other thing that ends
up happening is in your personal life
you also need to have a strong balance
sheet so you need to make sure that you
do everything you possibly can so that
you've got liquidity or capital whether
you want to simply make sure that you're
still around you can pay your bills you
can do the things you want to do in your
life and you're not drastically affected
by a recession
or you actually want to deploy capital
into the market so that you can drive
some sort of financial return either one
of those things is fine but you've got
to make sure that you take a look at
is my business balance sheet strong and
is my personal balance sheet strong
those are the two biggest things that
you can actually go ahead and control
now another thing you can control is
that you can get aggressive you can go
to work what i mean by that there are
over 11 million open jobs in america if
you work at a job right now that hasn't
given you a raise in the last two years
you should go find another job
if you work in a place where you're not
getting paid a ton of money but it's not
super hard you should go get a second
job you should do everything you
possibly can to drive revenue or income
for yourself so that you can shore up
that balance sheet and then go on
offense when you feel the time is right
and so naturally what i think
if you are in a position
strong balance sheet go to work whether
that is building a company from scratch
whether that is getting a second job
whether that is switching jobs whatever
go to work
get a strong balance sheet start working
hard the third thing you can do for many
of you pull out a notebook and start
learning
write down what's happening keep track
of the various events what is the
federal reserve saying what happens next
three months ago what did they say did
that happen did it not pay attention and
learning especially if you're a young
person there will be more
good times and bad times throughout your
life and so if you use this as a
learning opportunity you are getting
experience right now that people who
entered the market after 2010 for the
most part haven't experienced this and
so naturally i talked to an investor
yesterday and he said to me he said i
have an advantage right now i've lived
through two of these i lived through the
2001.com
uh bust and i or a 2000.com bust and i
also lived through the 2008 2009 global
financial crisis as an investor he says
he went out to silicon valley in the 90s
and so this is a third time he knows
exactly what to do what's the playbook
and i think that ends up being a really
important part too you are in control of
your learning right now so get a strong
balance sheet go to work and uh start
learning start paying attention and then
the last thing that i'll say is that one
of the things uh i always see occur uh
in good or bad times is people end up
going to the extremes from an emotional
standpoint you get too excited or you
get too down on yourself it's just money
it does not matter over the long period
of time in a sense of your happiness
is somewhat affected but you ultimately
can be happy even in the bad times from
a financial standpoint your stock
portfolio is down a lot you're not going
to sell stop worrying about it you're
not going to do anything different
anyways so move on with your life if
you've got a bunch of crypto and it's
down and no matter how low it goes
you're not going to sell it move on with
your life and just let time do its thing
and so i think these are the things that
end up occurring is that you need to be
able to look at yourself and say do i
have a strong balance sheet am i willing
to do the work right now to end up
driving more revenue for my business or
income personally am i willing to learn
and am i aware of my emotional state and
can i get myself into a position where i
am happier where i'm a clearer thinker
i'm calmer etc those are the things that
you can end up doing those are the
things that you're in control for now
i'm going to spend 40 minutes that's
pretty impressive actually 40 minutes
straight i'm going to spend about 10
minutes answering questions so if you
have questions drop them in the chat
right now i'll do my best to answer as
many as possible uh in the meantime i
have two things that i would love for uh
for you all to do the first is please
make sure you're subscribed to the
youtube channel we're gonna be doing
more of these videos as this continues
playing out the second thing is that uh
if um uh you can make sure that you like
the video uh that'll go ahead and uh
make sure more people on youtube see
this so hit the thumbs up on the youtube
video go ahead like that and also make
sure you're subscribed to the channel
and the last thing is uh the guys over
at ftx uh we've been working with them
now for a little bit they've given us
this link if you want to go check out
bitcoin cryptocurrencies you can go
there and they've got a bunch of uh
different things that you can do uh in
terms of uh getting various rewards for
opening an account i think for uh
beginning to trade uh or buy assets et
cetera so you can go check it out there
all right let's get into
uh
the
uh questions here
um
first is a good book so i always give
three recommendations on books uh the
best books that i think people can read
especially when you're younger this is
pretty much targeted younger people but
it benefits everyone uh rich dad poor
dad by robert kiyosaki i think is great
thinking grow rich is another great one
and the richest man in babylon uh is a
great book as well uh books that i've
been reading recently um i just got this
yesterday uh this is actually a really
great one build from uh tony fidel about
a third of the way through it uh is
pretty good uh there's a couple other
ones here uh this is uh one that makes
you just think more critically it's
called fossil future uh by alex epstein
uh why global human flourishing requires
more oil coal and natural gas not less
uh what else is here uh we got this one
amazon unbound jeff bezos and the
invention of a global empire you see
this here
so lots and lots of books uh i try my
best to read as much as possible it ends
up being uh pretty valuable um for
obvious reasons ray dalio's recent book
on the changing world order uh is also a
great one and then also a lot of
podcasts um as uh as well that ends up
being uh pretty effective all right what
other questions do we have here how long
do you think a recession could last six
to twelve months darren cooper um look
most recessions end up if they're kind
of a shallow recession could be you know
12 months uh you know the official
definition of a recession is two
consecutive quarters of gdp uh
contraction um but you know 12 months or
so is usually when people are affected
could go 18 a really bad recession be
like 24 months uh so kind of 12 to 24
months would be the historical uh norm
um but uh i i don't know i actually
don't know uh what uh uh what what is
going to happen here i think that for
most people if you can get in a position
where you say hey i'm going to be good
for like 18 months uh then you'll be in
good shape um how do i feel about
investing in energy or oil uh look i
know people who are fantastic investors
in
uh kind of the energy sector i'm not one
of them i don't have any advantage they
don't spend a lot of time thinking about
it uh but i do think uh chris that um
yeah there's obviously a lot of people
who made money uh over the last couple
of months specifically with all the
geopolitical uncertainty and yeah the
world runs on energy and so it's not
going to go to zero it's not going to go
away
i think just trying to figure out you
know what's your advantage how do you
actually get um some sort of uh um you
know exposure and what does that look
like what are your risk parameters uh
i'm not that guy but uh but there's
plenty of people out there that probably
can find that'll do it
um
sim asked what's your investing advice
over the next one to two years out what
are you investing in uh crypto real
estate commodity stocks etc so
definitely not advice i can tell you
what i'm doing uh but this is definitely
not financial advice uh i i've pretty
much uh outside of having to sell assets
uh to pay taxes i pretty much just buy
as many assets as i possibly can and my
goal is to hold them forever right that
that's my like overarching strategy and
so my current portfolio i've got um some
real estate i obviously have bitcoin
i've got a lot of exposure to private
market investing uh via venture capital
funds um either as an lp or or funds
where uh
i've managed the fund or as an angel
investor uh and then i um i pretty much
have no public market exposure other
than gbtc in a retirement account so i
don't think i have an advantage in the
public markets uh and it ends up not
being the risk reward uh that i'm
looking for so don't really play there i
don't have any um you know oil or any
sort of like commodity exposure like
that either so i'm pretty much real
estate crypto uh and then private market
investing uh and then also um i own
uh either majority or 100 percent of
businesses uh that have cash flow as
well and so uh from a from a sense
there's uh investments there uh also and
so when you think about that over the
next one to two years
my situation like i'm going to keep
doing what i was doing already uh i
don't have to make short term decisions
i'm i'm relatively young i'm in my early
30s uh and uh maybe i'm creeping into
mid 30s i don't know when you have to
change saying early to mid 30s uh but as
you look over the next two years nothing
in my life is going to change i'm not
here retirement age in the sense of uh
all of a sudden now i should start
selling my portfolio to live on or
anything like that
and um you know i have the ability to
assets i buy now if they go down further
i can just hold them until they recover
like i'm not a force seller i don't have
any uh major issues so a lot of it will
be i'll continue to obviously uh invest
in bitcoin i'll continue to invest in
private market uh companies and i'll
continue to invest in real estate and as
i continue to do those three things from
a pure investment portfolio standpoint
i'll also continue to build companies as
well but that's why the strategy is
don't
do that much different um and it tends
to uh to work out um because again think
if this is a 12 month situation if
you're making decisions today
and you're panicking but you could have
lasted for 12 months anyways then you
you should be okay um and so i don't
think that you want to panic right now i
don't think you want to uh get in a uh a
bad situation um i see
edh420 says do you share elon's
nervousness about the economy i don't
know if you should say i'm nervous uh i
think there's a lot of uncertainty
there's a lot of questions there's more
questions than answers and so you know i
just went over kind of how we got to the
situation that we're in um and the big
question is if we have high inflation of
over eight percent right now and the fed
is increasing interest rates and
conducting quantitative tightening how
quickly does that inflation come down uh
i don't think at this point given what
the actions they're doing it would be
hard for me to see uh inflation
continuing in the official cpi metrics
into the double digits i do think that
we've likely uh seen kind of the peak of
the inflation um again i you know i
reserve the right to change my mind uh
and maybe i'm like 70 confident in that
um but but it seems like you know given
that the last uh inflation reading came
down a little bit they're also hiking
rates they're conducting quantitative
tightening uh we should see inflation
start to come down you also have the
base effect uh going in june uh where uh
now it's compounding growth it's not
just off of kind of flat numbers so
that'll help bring the number down as
well i think um and so the big question
is just like even though the inflation
official number comes down there's still
inflation in the economy and if they're
raising rates they're conducting
quantitative tightening there's
geopolitical uncertainty there's a
midterm election looming like what
happens
i don't know and so that uncertainty
ends up uh i think driving what uh this
person asked about like nervousness and
when there's uncertainty people just
don't want to make a mistake and so what
they end up doing is they say let's
pause hiring let's slow down a little
bit let's all chill out here let's not
act real crazy um and so i think that
can be
a good way to look at it
uh ranger the dog uh which hopefully i
don't know if that's my brother joe or
or if that's somebody else asks uh what
are the biggest risks bitcoin faces
you know i think that bitcoin is in a
very unique position in that um the
biggest risk is actually a internal risk
meaning that i don't worry about um
geopolitical risk i don't worry about um
an external hack of bitcoin or anything
like that i think probably the biggest
risk and i'll caveat this with saying
like it is essentially a
zero percent risk nothing zero percent
risk uh but but it's a very very very
low probability uh is some sort of
self-induced wound bitcoin is uh
software that software still has people
maintaining it it still gets updated
and the development process is uh very
much methodical it's intentional
it's somewhat slow in order to ensure
that there's nothing that ends up
getting broken there's 800 billion or so
of economic value at stake here and
we're trying to build a system that's
going to last for centuries and so
there's no rush um but just making sure
that that there's no uh you know bug or
anything like that introduced i think is
important obviously as do the developers
um so to me like it's more of like the
balls in our court and uh and we're
likely to make the biggest mistakes uh
another i don't want to say is a risk
but it's something to pay attention to
um is definitely this uh esg narrative
you see these politicians running around
you score political points for talking
about it but when uh these academic
theories meet reality uh reality wins
and so take new york new york recently
discussed uh this idea of a moratorium
on new miners that aren't 100 renewable
and the politician who put it forward
said oh everyone's taking this out of
context it's not going to have a bad uh
impact don't worry everyone's freaking
out
whatever and uh i i believe it's a woman
who said uh you know we're not gonna
lose economic value because it's not
gonna hurt our economy but at the same
time she's saying all this
50 of the miners in new york have left
over the last like year
so it's an academic theory oh this
doesn't have a big issue we shouldn't
worry about it's not a problem don't
worry uh it's not gonna hurt our economy
at the same time
50 of the miners left so reality meets
academic theory reality wins i think
that's an important uh piece of it is
like this esg narrative it's just a pain
in the ass cause we gotta deal with it
we gotta answer it gotta talk about it
what ends up happening is that esg is a
complete scan the whole thing is just
full of nonsense uh and so naturally i
think reality will win out but the
academic theory uh is something that has
to be addressed and then the other thing
is uh i still think that taxation uh in
the united states you know if you really
think about especially in the united
states uh if i go to dinner tonight and
i buy dinner
with dollars uh i pay for the price of
the meal i tip the waiter or waitress
and i pay sales tax and i walk out of
the restaurant if i buy it in bitcoin i
end up paying for the price of the meal
i tip the waiter or waitress i pay sales
tax and then i pay capital gains on the
bitcoin
and so naturally there's a fairly
abrasive
tax treatment because treated as
property and so i think that that's
going to have to get solved over time
it's not a risk it's just something that
needs to uh kind of uh be addressed if
you will
um
all right so i'm gonna take two more
questions and i got things i gotta go do
uh
before that make sure you like the video
make sure you subscribe to the channel
let's see um
we'll ask the question are past
long-term bear markets comparable to
current markets now that investing has
been democratized and we now have
millions of digits wanting to play the
tickers with their monthly paychecks
it's a great question right there's been
more gamification of markets uh there's
been loser monetary policy last couple
of years etc uh i do though probably
more so than most people in the bitcoin
or crypto industry uh put weight on
history i think that history is a great
guide um and it boils down to one simple
thing and this isn't my idea you know
plenty of other investors have talked
about it like human nature doesn't
change
and so naturally if you can understand
past market cycles whether it's stocks
commodities real estate uh
uh or or crypto human nature doesn't
change and sure there's nuanced
differences uh there can be
macroeconomic differences all that but
the same things end up occurring when
prices go down people panic and they
sell people who have strong balance
sheets and liquidity and the courage to
believe in the long-term value of the
assets and they select well they end up
doing really well right there's this
whole thought process of
kind of fortunes are made in the bear
markets and they're reaped in the bull
markets and i think that that ends up
being a a pretty good way to uh to view
the world so you know i i pay attention
to history a lot i like to read a lot um
but
i don't necessarily know uh if
everyone's doing that since that would
be one uh one big thing um
and then uh let's see ease inbox what do
you think about arthur hayes theory the
boomer the boomers will force the fed to
help risk on uh i don't know exactly
what arthur said i know he recently
published a piece i haven't had the
chance to read it yet so i'll go tonight
and i'll i'll take a look at it and have
different thoughts um but yeah i do
think that uh there's a relationship i'm
assuming what he's talking about i gotta
be careful with assumptions but i'm
assuming what he's talking about is uh a
lot of uh fixed income assets a lot of
kind of older folks whether it's
pensions uh their retirement accounts
etc they're getting decimated right now
and so if all of a sudden you have the
baby boomers who are all moving to
retirement age their uh portfolios are
getting decimated uh they're gonna start
applying pressure and the first place
that they're gonna apply pressure is at
the ballot box uh in november they're
gonna show up and look you know uh
people who vote are uh are very unique
characters because uh what usually
happens is there's tons of talk about
politicians and politics and this you
know cause with this cause this caused
this cost at the end of the day the
majority of people my my personal belief
is majority of people care about one
thing their pocketbook and if you end up
being in an environment where they're
making lots of money then likely what
happens is that they're going to be
sympathetic to you and uh kind of your
political party if you end up hurting
their pocketbook they come and they try
to vote you out and so with gasoline at
4.50 on a national average with uh asset
prices falling off a cliff
this year in a midterm election year uh
i don't think it looks very good for the
democrats right now now again there will
be some that are outliers and they're
fine uh and there will be some that you
know are running unopposed there'll be
some that are running against you know
incompetent candidates whatever but i
think overall uh there's kind of a
wake-up call that's coming
because at the end of the day voters
care about one thing which is their
pocketbook uh and so i do think that
boomers or baby boomers uh end up being
uh very very very concerned right now
because you know again if you go back to
2020 this last uh uh thing i'll leave
you guys with
in march of 2020 when the stock market
went down 25 30 percent gold's down 15
bitcoin down
uh all of a sudden
they
prices went down prices go down because
people are selling and they rocketed
back after the central bank intervened
and there was a study done that said
well who was selling during that point
and one of the biggest portions of
people that were selling at the bottom
of the march 2020 market were people who
were either in retirement or close to
retirement age
and the reason was because if they had
lived through the global financial
crisis in 2007 2008 they had to wait in
some cases five years before their asset
prices got back and a bunch of them said
i'll just take the twenty percent
haircut now just give me the cash i want
the cash i want security i can't though
this goes down forty percent fifty
percent i can't stomach that and so
naturally what occurred is uh you end up
getting people uh who sold the bottom
who actually need the money and so same
thing's happening now was a bunch of
people near retirement or in retirement
that are older uh they're freaking out
and so i do think that there's some uh
kind of credibility to the theory that
uh they're going to end up um you know
pressuring the fed and saying hey you
can't keep you can't intentionally crash
the stock market and push us into a
recession uh because you guys were so
incompetent that you got us to uh the
high inflation
what are you doing
and i think that's going to be a big big
problem for folks so
that's uh that that's kind of my
thoughts right now um if uh for those of
you um before i let you guys go uh let
me i'll leave you guys with a couple of
a couple of things that are probably uh
important so if this stuff is uh uh is
valuable and you enjoy this stuff i just
put into the chat right now a link uh i
write a daily letter to um about 220 000
investors uh it's every morning uh goes
out i talk about business finance
economics bitcoin um kind of what the
fed's doing how to figure out markets uh
asset prices etc so you can click on
that link and you can subscribe there uh
or you can also leave it as the pinned
comment on the video after we shut it
off so uh make sure you subscribe there
to that a lot of folks uh probably
benefit from that enjoy that and then
also if uh if you're interested um ftx
is uh giving out a bunch of rewards if
you want to go buy bitcoin they've got
super low fees they're adding uh they've
got a beta right now for uh stocks where
there's no uh
there's no transaction fees there's no
payment for order flow etc i dropped
that link as well you can go in and uh
and sign up and get some rewards uh i
think what you create an account or once
you uh start to uh uh to transact on
that platform so uh i hope you guys
enjoyed this uh i had an hour sitting
here so i figured i'd just jump on and
uh go ahead and record make sure you
like the video uh if we can get uh man i
don't know maybe 2500 likes or so on the
video usually they do pretty well uh and
then also make sure that you're
subscribed to the channel i'll start
trying to do these a little bit more
often just keep everyone updated on kind
of what's going on uh how we got to
where we are uh where i think we're
going and then answer some questions but
other than that love you all i
appreciate all of you uh hanging out on
youtube twitter uh reading the uh the
email every day and if i can do anything
to help you guys i will do the best i
can but until next time see you guys
later